Okay.
Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Monday morning
podcast for Monday, Monday,
December 4th,
2000 and fucking
17. Yeah, that'd be great.
I just realized I just gave a fuck and
just gave Dean del Rey a check and I
wrote December 5th on it. I thought
tomorrow was December 5th. Well,
it is by the time you hear this, but
I did this Sunday night. Now fuck it.
Tell him not to deposit the check. Well
they can. You can still deposit it right?
And then they don't fucking whatever.
I del Ray opened for me this weekend.
Holy Shit. We got the levels up
too high here. There are too high.
I can't hear myself thinking here.
For God sakes.
Could you just shut it
down please. Thank you. Um,
dude, I'm fucking sitting there. What do,
and I'm sitting there minding my own
business in my house, my fucking house.
Fuck you bankers. It's my now until
I die. And then you get it back.
Don't you get cuts? Um,
they just sit there waiting.
If you have a pay off your house,
look out your window.
There'll be a banker sitting out there
like a fucking like a God damn vulture
waiting for you to fucking look at.
Look at him. Look at him eating bacon.
I guess Bacon's good fee.
Now I don't know what the fuck.
I don't know what I know what
I'm talking about. Um, anyways,
um, I wonder what room I'm
going to die in this house.
You ever think about that
when you just get the house?
Like I'm not fucking leaving. I'm staying
here. Right? And then you just, when you,
once you make that decision you like,
but then I'm going to fucking die in here.
What room is it going to be? I think a
lot of people die at breakfast nooks.
You know,
just sitting down and having some toast.
Read the morning paper.
That wouldn't be a bad way to go.
Let's go face down until like fucking
half piece of grapefruit. Alrighty.
What room would you want to die? And you
don't want to do it in the shower, right?
That's fucking awful. Then you're all
waterlogged, you know, Bang your head on.
The fucking lot of people die in
the shower. They slip and fall,
you know,
and they can't get up right.
And that's why they came
out with that fucking,
that thing there for all the old people.
But what a lot of people don't realize
is a lot of them fall in the fucking
shower and then they did
go to use their little,
I've fallen and I can't get up thing.
And then they get electrocuted.
I don't think that happens,
but I would be worried about that.
Trying to drag my old pruned
as out of the fucking tub.
Oh my God. That's gotta be the
worst. When you get so old,
you're afraid to take a shower.
You got to bring like a
fucking lazy boy in there.
Oh Shit. I'm sorry. That just
fucking struck we, it's funny,
he just got a giant lazy,
you got a recliner in your
shower so it's waterproof.
I don't know the fuck you.
I liked.
I love that flashlight that just came out
that, that, that runs on water. I mean,
give me, what are we doing? What the
fuck are we doing in the Middle East?
Jesus Christ.
Just put that in a fucking car stick
20 olds flashlights in the car.
I'll drive slower. Let's just
get out of there already, right?
The fuck we think we're doing.
You don't find the Middle East is like,
Molly's is like you're a civilian and
you get in the middle of like a domestic
violence fucking incident, you
know, and you try to break it up,
you know, and the second you go to break
it up, the woman starts beating on you.
I get off my abusive husband.
That's what it's like over there.
Just fucking get those water flashlights.
This is what you do.
You get those water flashlights and
you put them into fucking Scotus that
everybody has to ride his scooter.
Whether you're fat or old or whatever.
You got to ride one and cars are illegal.
All right?
The amount of people wipe
it out, dying, right.
Frees up the fucking traffic.
We're not using as much oil and
then they go bankrupt over there.
How about that there? Did I
solve the Middle East Obama
me to do that every week.
Every week I'm going to have a new
fucking solution for the Middle East. Um,
anyway, I don't want the fuck
I'm talking about. I just,
can you imagine just having a
giant fucking recliner, you know,
and then you have like that little grabby
thing and you just turn on the fucking
water. What are those grabby
things? You know, you fucking, you,
you pull the handle and, and you've
got an x, like the fucking groceries.
They always grab like a
can of soup or some shit.
Yeah.
What,
why are you bringing from Broccoli
whenever they go up there and they fucking
Yank it down? I don't if that
doesn't happen anymore. There's no,
there's no regular person running a
fucking grocery store anymore. Is there?
Okay.
Grocery stores is a fucking weird man.
Dot.
It can kind of like the
food version of a casino.
Like he just feel like there's somebody
up in the ceiling watching you buying
like a two way mirror.
When you go in there,
there's really nothing
stopped. But yeah, man,
one time I walked to this grocery store
with Patrice and we acted like fucking
children. He got me going
like he was so fucking silly.
I remember one time he just goes,
uh,
we will go on and he was staying
at my apartment for pilot season.
Both of us creeps trying to get on my CTV.
Yeah. How do you think that worked out?
So,
um,
we were in like Ralph's of some shit
and he just kept going. They bill,
you want some of these?
And when he would go to point at it,
he would like key to have his hand
way too close to the bag, the bag,
any like it was like bread or something.
He goes, Bill, you need some of this.
And he would,
he would just push his finger into like
fucking three slices of bread through
the wrapper.
And he just started doing that around the
grocery store and I was fucking crying,
laughing.
He did it.
The cookies he was doing is doing it to
fruit and these giant fucking fingers.
Hey Bill,
you want one of these things?
Just like all the way
through the fucking thing.
And I'm immature is fuck. And it was
just making me fucking cry, laugh.
And he's a comedian, so he just kept
doing it and I was trying to do it.
I could even, you know, my fingers were,
I don't know. I was laughing too hard.
I couldn't fucking do it as
good as him. Um, anyways, Geez.
I hadn't thought about that for
fucking ever. And I want to apologize.
Maybe it wasn't Ralph's. Where the fuck,
where are we? I always hated rouse,
you know, she's a fucking pain in the
ass. The one that was down the street.
I used to live office
sunset and there was a,
Ralphs used to be called rock and roll.
Ralph's, everything was rock and roll.
Denny's rock and roll. Ralph's steps back
like leftover from the hair metal shit.
You know the rock and roll Hyatt right
next to fucking the comedy store.
John Bonham used to ride motorcycles.
There's some shit into the fucking thing.
I Dunno what?
MMM.
I have no idea. I don't what the fuck
it was. I even know where we were at.
MMM.
Jesus Christ. I have a side of that. And
Fred, what the fuck was I talking about?
It's talking about being an old man,
but there were cleaner
and a God damn shower,
whatever that moments come and gone.
That's what happens on the podcast.
I just fucking talk and whatever
happens, it happens. By the way,
I would like to thank everybody
that came out to Albuquerque,
New Mexico. I had a great fucking
time at route 66 casino. I've,
that's the second time I played there.
I fucking loved that place to crowd
was awesome. And then the next, uh,
the next last night I played in
Tucson, Arizona, another great town,
just fucking great people,
great parts of the country, um,
fun fucking crowds. And
um, I gotta tell Ya,
I'm acting like a fucking idiot on stage.
Like at,
I think it's my reaction to this fucking,
this,
this weird fog that is starting to roll
in slowly rolling in over the last five
years on standup comedy where all of a
sudden I sit there on stage and sometimes
I think after I say something like,
did somebody record that?
Am I going to get into trouble?
I haven't thought,
I never thought that the first fucking
20 years of my career in the last five
years, it just keeps creeping into my
head. And in order to beat it down, I, I,
yeah,
I dunno. I think I've gone a
little harder. Somebody got,
there's gotta be some sort of pushback
on this fucking vibe that's out there
that everything is so god damn serious.
Now Jesus fucking Christ.
Couple guys want to be women.
A couple of guys take their dicks
out at work and then all of a sudden
everybody's got to go, whew.
How did he mean that joke?
Is that a joke or is that
legislation for a new law?
Like this whole fucking vibe that's out
there. It's, it's, it's really weird.
Okay.
It fucking young people are
acting like old people, you know?
And I think that's because they're on
social media and all that shit and they're
just watching this stuff.
24 seven. It's like fucking,
I don't know.
It's fucking up their brains.
I mean, come on millennials,
you've got to do something. That spot
you're supposed to make me uncomfortable.
Donors and bureau. Jack Crunch.
What are they going, you know?
I guess they have that new
documentary, Meth town on fucking, uh,
Hbo. D Del Ray told me to wash it.
I can't fucking watch that shit.
I'm not going to watch a
bunch of toothless fucking
people. Those goddamn people,
I swear to God, they look like
they're from the 18 hundreds.
That's how bad they fuck their
faces up with that meth shit.
I'll tell you, once you lose your
fucking teeth, he look like you're 80.
I don't care how old you are.
You could take one of those
gorgeous Victoria's secret
models that if they don't
have any fucking teeth,
they didn't get a partial or a fucking
implants or whatever the fuck you call
them. Dentures is some shit. If
you just walk around toothless,
you immediately look,
you look like homer Simpson's
fucking that guy that falls asleep.
His Dad is his dad.
Um,
that grandfather, right? I
Dunno. Yeah. So I had that on.
I was talking to someone on the
phone and dean kept telling me,
what you got to see it, dude, you
got to see. And even dean said, man,
I fucking shut this thing off like three
times. He goes, it's fucking brutal.
So I just had the sound down and I was
watching all these toothless fucking
people with these crazy
looks on their faces. And uh,
I was on the phone and at one point
I just saw somebody kicking dog shit,
like piles of dog shit,
different piles all around the house,
like hoarding dog shit out of the way in
this person's house with newspaper all
over it and stuff. And um,
that's when I turned the channel.
I don't know about you guys,
but I drew the line at the, uh,
I drew the line at the dog.
Shit,
there's a few things that make
me turn the channel. Okay.
Drug addicts would dog
shit in their house and,
and strong female characters
make me turn the channel.
And not because I have anything
against a strong female character.
It's just that they don't develop them.
I think everybody in Hollywood is so
afraid of getting yelled at by these
women's groups that they just throw
in these strong female characters,
but they don't, they don't make
a three dimensional character.
They just have a woman yelling at guys
and grabbing them by their fucking lapels
of their suit and throw
them over couches and shit.
It's like they took like leftover Steven
Seagal Shit and the guy will give it to
the woman he or see she strung all of a
sudden every fucking shy a fuck you with
Dick and balls
to like,
who is this fucking Parson sky outweighs
there by like a fucking hundred pounds.
What am I,
what am I watching?
I watched that recently.
I might even say the fucking show,
but I'm watching this guy,
this guy's like 40 fucking years old.
He's talking to a 19 year old redneck
woman who lives next to a fucking lake in
the middle of Arkansas and she's having
a battle of wits with them and she's
winning like Jesus fucking Christ.
The Fun.
What kind of a fucking 19 year old could
beat a fucking 50 year old guy in a
battle of wits once it talking about
fucking did $10 whatever the fucking kids
play in the Ted though.
Sorry. Whatever you guys play.
Yeah.
Um, I'm not a Gamer. All right.
I used to be a Bose sound.
I'm still not drinking the fuck is it?
It's a one of my a hundred and
some days in at this point.
It's one oh five days,
three days in and it's one oh eight we
went oh nine by the time you listened to
this thing. But I gotta tell you
I'm fucking, I'm getting weak.
I'm getting a week.
All the holidays are rolling in.
I think I'll be good through December,
but uh,
I'm going to the fucking rose bowl again
this year. This is my 10th. Rosebowl.
Alright. It's the 10 anniversary for
me and Joe Barton. Nick the originals,
the original fucking drunk
maniacs at that game.
And what's so fucking awesome now about
the college football playoff is that
every three years now,
the Rosebowl is a playoff game.
Last time it was a Florida state
and Oregon, I believe. Uh, Jameson,
Winston and uh, the guy from
fucking a Tennessee, Tyson's,
I can't remember his name. Mary
Yoda. Is that the coach? I know.
What the fuck the guy from
Oregon, he's great. Right? Um,
and this year it's going to be the
Oklahoma sooners versus the fucking,
uh, who else got in? Let's see.
It's Clemson versus
Alabama and then we got a,
the fucking Oklahoma's playing.
Whoa. Nobody in the big 10 got in.
Yeah.
TCU got their fucking asses kicked
and whenever I watch Tcu, they win.
Can't believe I fucking miss that.
Who the fuck is Oklahoma player?
Yeah.
Wasn't Wisconsin. Clemson is
Alabama. I got to hit pause here.
This is going to draw a fuck that you guys
can listen. How dumb I am. I know this.
USC didn't get in.
It's gotta be a conference.
Fucking champion Miami laws to Clemson.
Auburn didn't get in.
Who the fuck is it? I've got to hit
pause. I don't know the fuck it is.
I'm an asshole. Georgia. I
actually didn't look it up.
I just sat there and I
fucking started thinking like,
who the fuck else is in there?
Miami Central Florida,
Florida State, South Carolina,
gators, Georgia. That's how I did it.
Started down, I was stuck down in
Miami and it fucking worked my way up.
The George, Jim, Georgia bulldogs. And I
know there's a lot of people were upset.
A lot of people were upset that a,
it's such a flawed fucking system. Um,
I know Jay [inaudible] was telling me
that fucking Alabama didn't play anybody.
He's like, they didn't fucking play
anybody. And then I'm thinking like, well,
the big 10 was in his fucking,
you know,
Wisconsin being undefeated is amazing
until you fucking look at the,
you know,
the western side of the fucking big 10
Nebraska stanks Illinois was pathetic.
Indiana stakes, Minnesota, stags,
Northwestern was decent. They
were seven and two, but I mean,
if they won that last seven games,
but they played nobody.
Um, and I always sit in there
going like, so I'm like,
what the fuck is he talking about?
You know,
it's like you guys lost a fucking
Iowa. I was, was halfway decent.
Penn state was overrated. What the fuck
you talking about? So you know what I did?
I actually listened to Jay law head and
I looked up the fucking Alabama crimson
tide's fucking schedule
and I gotta tell you,
I think I could've got them
five fucking winds. J lie ahead.
Sorry j lie had I owe an apology to
this is who they play. Florida state.
Who stinks then they played Colorado
state at, I don't need what they,
those fucking people should be
selling insurance out there.
Get rid of that football team.
Mississippi. They stink this year.
Arkansas stunk this year. Lsu. You
know Lee came on late, but they stink.
I love them. Mercer. Is that
a woman's college? I didn't
know who the fuck that is.
Fresno state. I went to that game. Fresno
state. You know, I'd say they stink,
but I've watched too many
of those behind the scenes.
Things about fragrance
[inaudible] carriers. I'm not
gonna say shit about Fresno.
I'm just saying,
you know,
they could have been a little
better Vanderbilt at too
fucking smart to be good.
Texas a and M, they stunk.
Tennessee fucking stanks.
Mississippi state was decent and they
played Auburn who is a good fucking team.
And they lost. However they did
beat the shit out of people.
They want 24,
740120360 six to three 41 and nine.
They did beat the fuck out of people.
56 that nothing against a woman's college.
41 to 10 59 and nothing
against Vanderbilt.
Don't they play a bunch
of fucking architects. Uh,
Nate Barr Godsy was starting
at fucking punter 27,
19 against the Texas a and
m 45, seven. Hey by the way,
all those students that fuck that guy
out of that fucking head coaching job at
Tennessee were those signs
that they wrote, was that true?
And how? Cause they really
fucking, I don't know man.
I hope they did some research this
whole fucking trial by Internet.
Um, I left to look that up man. Cause that
just, that was like fucking and stuff.
Some of the shit that people wrote on
site. He was at Penn state. I don't know,
during the whole time or part of the
time when that Sandusky guy was there.
But it's just like,
you know,
yeah,
it's, I don't understand this. I love
how the, like one guy does some shit,
then all of a sudden,
like the most horrific fucking
thing you could do a basically,
and then all of a sudden everybody
fucking knew and nobody said anything.
Everybody.
Yeah.
I'm not saying they weren't
a few people like, oh Jesus,
we got fucking protecting the university,
but just anybody who was there
as automatically fucking guilty.
Some of these fucking
kids, man. I, you know,
this whole trial by fucking social
media is a little out of control there.
But anyways, I'm, I'm going,
going off the rails here. Um,
so I dunno. We'll see. We'll
see. What the fuck happens. Uh,
I know Jay was upset that Ohio state
didn't get in. I, you got to tell you, oh,
have stayed at a tougher schedule
than fucking Alabama. Easily,
easily at a tougher fucking schedule.
But what about, what about Auburn?
What about Arbor man, they beat
Georgia when they were number one.
Then they beat Alabama. They,
they be too fucking number once.
Then they had to go back and beat
fucking Georgia Gandy couldn't do it.
You know what happened with that?
That fucking Auburn's coach
opened his big fat fucking mouth.
We kicked a dog crap out of them.
Did we?
We don't check the dog crap out of
them. Didn't, but you know what I mean?
I hope every fucking person
who's in, um, sports journalism,
I hope they watch that.
They see that fucking clip and then you
see the fucking Georgia bulldogs showing
up the next game with flames coming
out of their fucking nostrils.
You know,
the next time you're going to sit there
and trash bill Belicheck and say he's
quote unquote was so boring
and his press conferences,
that's because the man is a genius.
Bill Belicheck is never going to be like,
we kicked the dog crap
out about dirt work.
We captain fucking dog crap on the boom.
Why the fuck would you say that?
You know,
it says that the kind of guy who wears a
fucking golf in hand when he's coaching
a football team,
um,
what a dumb fuck it think that that is
the stupidest fucking thing you can do
better when the fucking cowboys will
fucking kicking the shit out of the
Steelers and like Superbowl nine or
10, I don't know, about 40 years ago.
You have a look at those highlights and
fucking Roy g irrele missed that field
goal and stupid as cliff
Harris got in his face,
patted him on the fucking helmet and
then Lambert came over and just body slam
cliff Harris back when you could do that
and there wasn't a fucking, you know,
a bunch of fines and you had to go fucking
sing acapella to some fuck a woman's
group. Whatever the fucking punishment
is now. Right. You could do that.
That turned the tide of the game.
Keep your fucking mouth shut until you're
holding the championship trophy and
then you don't need to talk shit cause
you want it. You fucking Ugh. What?
I kept the dog crap out of him.
And what happened?
She played him a few weeks later. You get
the old right there, Fred, don't you? Um,
so anyways, so it was a lot of
'em. There was a lot of uh, um,
I was 100% wrong. I thought j Lo
head was just being a fucking homer.
He was absolutely fucking right.
Alabama didn't play anybody,
but they scored a lot of fucking
points. Who knows? We'll see.
We'll see. Now if Alabama goes in
and wins the whole fucking thing,
then what does that do?
I actually like how vague this is and
how many arguments that it creates.
Just a whole fuck, you know? And
at the end of the day, you can't,
you can't open this up to some
giant fucking march madness.
The game is just simply
to fucking violent.
I love that it's four teams and I love
that people get left out, you know,
the same way.
I love seeing a little kid crying because
his mother wouldn't get him the toy
that he wanted. That just warms
my heart whenever I see that.
He'd seen a little spoiled
brats like, yeah, fuck you.
I gave you cheerios this morning. Didn't
you didn't I, you know, meanwhile,
I'm going to spoil the
shit out of my daughter.
I'm all over the map here and what
the fuck I'm talking about. Um,
so that's what I did all day.
Uh,
all day on fry our Friday and Saturday.
I just watch fucking college football
other than when I was traveling,
going out to
the fuck that I fly out to Albuquerque,
New Mexico. And he was funny.
It was a six hour drive
from Albuquerque to Tucson.
I should have done that.
I wasn't paying attention.
I actually flew down and rather
than getting a direct flight,
I had to connect through Phoenix.
So it was the fire.
I could have flown from La to
the Goddamn Columbus, Ohio,
you know, and uh, speaking
of buckeyes right in that,
the amount of time that
it took me in this,
the fucking person who flew us
from Phoenix, from, from uh,
Albuquerque to Phoenix. Okay.
We're taxiing out to get to the,
uh, I don't know, on our way
out to the runway. Right.
And the guide bags a left and then
quickly goes back to the right.
And I was just like, Whoa, what the
fuck? And I was like, why? You know,
maybe it was the tower.
Maybe they said make a left on a bravo
or ah, I mean, right. Sorry. Right.
Correction, go right on. Bravo. Right.
So I got this app where I
can listen to the tower.
So I put it on to here to try and
listen to see if I could hear anything,
which I couldn't.
So we take off flights,
great flying,
everything's fine.
Not No fucking problems would
come in and go land, land.
Landing was nice and everything. And
then we're going in. But taxing in,
we go into, get into the [inaudible]
where you parked the plane,
whatever the fuck he called it,
the gate. And this fucking guy,
he literally did a donut.
He did a three 60 with the
airplane he wants again,
went left when he was supposed to go.
Right. And we fucking did an entire three.
Not that,
maybe not an entire three 60.
I think he just missed the gay and he
just drove by it and then he couldn't go
right into it because he would have
hit the other plane. So we had to,
because it was on the right hand side,
he had a bang, the left and we lose it.
Did like a fucking doubt it. And
everybody's in the play. Like,
what the fuck are we doing?
Guide a bad day. He or she,
whoever the fuck was up
front, um, it was hilarious.
Everybody was getting off the
plane. I do. What the fuck was that?
The hell just happened. You
know what happens? You know,
you drive down the street,
sometimes you miss the home depot. Like,
yeah, fuck, I gotta go back around again.
I don't feel like doing it legally. And
you just fucking bang a Uie. Right. Well,
the same thing happens in aviation,
evidently ever fucking deadly.
The same thing happens. Um, Jesus,
what the fuck is going on
in Kansas City by the way?
They lost to the New York jets,
jets at decent.
Okay,
good Lord. This is why, you know,
coaching in the NFL has got to be a bitch.
Can you imagine Andy Reed
after September starts to year,
they, they fucking beat the dog.
That the fair, we beat the dog crap.
All of them fucking Patriot
show like right. Not really.
They just dominated the fourth quarter
and ran away with it at that point. Right?
Everybody's all excited. Holy
Shit. Then all of a sudden,
Tom Brady's fucking old and uh,
the fucking water goes down the drain
the different way. Black is white, white.
He's black.
You don't know what the fuck's going on
all the way through September. I bet he,
we started at building an addition
onto his fucking house, you know,
getting ready to put that
fucking trophy in there. And uh,
after these last two fucking months,
the last eight goddamn weeks,
I would say that the,
that they've stopped the construction,
he probably has a tarp over the
top of it. Um, I like Andy Reid.
I hope they turn it around.
I haven't been able to watch the game,
but Jesus fucking Christ,
they can't get a goddamn when
they cannot get a fucking win.
So, um, I actually watched a bunch of
football today too when I, when I landed,
I watched the Patriots first,
the bills.
I thought that was gonna
be a lot closer game.
I thought tie Rod Taylor was going
to give us headaches. All right,
tie Rod Taylor. I liked that
guy, but I'll tell you right now,
he is no Russell Wilson.
And after watching the fucking Seattle
Seahawks tonight I'm going to go out on a
limb.
I think I could block for Russell Wilson.
I could just have a guy in about eight
seconds run around me and then just watch
him fucking be like this
modern day Fran target did.
That guy is fucking unbelievable.
I don't even know how good
Seattle's offensive line is.
I don't even know if they're decent.
All I know is at the end of
every game they should be giving.
They should be fucking making it rain at
Russell Wilson's locker because they're
all going to get a big contract because
I guarantee you he probably got sacked
probably, I dunno what, three times,
four times less than he should have.
The fucking eagles were in the backfield.
Oh,
it was like every time we
went back for the past,
the guy had run like an extra 40
yards until somebody got opened.
The Guy, I'm like, I dunno.
Like I felt like they got maybe two
or three times that game maybe. Um,
but Jesus Christ is that guy fun to watch
and Seattle looks to Seattle look fun.
They look really strong,
man.
I was actually kind of like root for
the Eagles because, uh, you know,
I don't know what the
Patriots going to do. I,
you never know when you're
playing the AFC east, you know,
that's our fucking schedule is like
the Alabama Crimson tide. You don't,
Dolphin Stank bill stink that Jed stink
this year. They're all fucking average.
You know what I mean? There's literally
six wins right there. Um, so I,
I really don't know how good we are,
but, uh, that was a huge game tonight.
This always feels like a sports podcast.
I did start off talking about fucking
old people in Lazy Boys, right? Didn't I?
And I, I also believe I solved
the Middle Eastern crisis.
MMM.
I just watch, I'm sorry. I just watched
a ton of fucking football and uh,
well at this point you gotta be the
football if you're still listening.
So I'm not gonna apologize.
I should apologize like
fucking 10 minutes ago. But,
um, I dunno. The defense
looked fucking great. Richard
Sherman isn't even in there.
Can I ask you guys a fucking question
about the Achilles Tendon? Why do,
why do you rupture your Achilles
tendon but you tear your ACL?
Why is that?
Why don't you rupture your ACL and
tear your fucking Achilles Tendon?
Why is that? Is it because
your Achilles tendon goes up?
You fought back he leg like
a fucking window shade?
Is that what it is? You don't, I'm
actually going to look that up.
I'm going to look that up.
I'm going to put this fucking urban myth.
This is it a room with bill? No,
it's not. It's uh, I don't know.
It's a fucking question I have.
Why?
Yeah.
Do you rupture a,
that's not going to come out right?
Your Achilles. Okay. Wait,
now because there'll be like,
cause you fucking didn't stretch.
That's a wrong way to search. How about
rupture?
Verse Tear.
Achilles. All right, and let's see
what we got here. What do we got here?
Yeah.
Achilles tendon rupture is an injury that
affects the back of your lower leg. Oh,
is that where it is?
Jesus Christ.
All right. It mainly occurs in
people playing recreational sports.
That means white guys playing pickup hoop.
Every fucking white dude.
I know over the age of 40, 35, 40,
who still plays hoops that every
one of them gets to Coby injury.
But it can happen to anyone.
That's why before you get out of bed,
if you're a fucking old person,
especially an old white guy. All right?
I don't know. I mean the main black
guys other than than, than fucking, uh,
Richard Sherman and Koby Bryant like
superstar black guys do it right,
but average white people
just all the fucking time.
I'm just making up shit here before
you get out of bed in the morning.
I'm telling you, if you, if you run a
little tight, okay, I'm telling you,
I've said this before,
you fucking take your toes,
point them at your knees slowly.
All right? And if you get an a,
if you get a fucking Charlie horse in
your fucking calves immediately point your
toes in the other direction and a
little release. Okay? But if you don't,
just point in your fucking do it right
now. Your desk, what the fuck are you?
Do you not doing shit right? But
will you sit down right? Don't do it.
Wait to fucking lay it down. Don't listen
to me, but I'm still gonna talk to you.
Right? Point your toes at
Unis and your knee caps.
That's saw you do. And you just do that
for a good, I don't know, 1520 seconds.
Right?
Then you pointed with the other direction
that the fucking wall or whatever,
I'm sitting in front of you.
All right,
your dog that's laying on
the end of your bed, okay?
Then once you do that for 15 seconds,
then you roll your fucking feet clockwise
a couple times and counterclockwise.
Then you get out of bed.
Don't just lay there for fucking
eight hours sleeping with you,
God damn apnea and then just pop out
of bed and take that first step because
you're going to get you get you
gotta be fucked. Plant Fisher, right?
It's all that bullshit, right? Let's,
let's continue with the Achilles tendon.
Is he strong?
Fiber is cord that connects the muscles
in the back of your calf to your heel
bone. If you overstretch your
Achilles tendon, it can tear. Fuck,
wait a minute.
I thought it was cause you didn't
tear slash rupture completely or just
partially hits your
Achilles tendon ruptures.
You might hear a pop followed
by an immediate bitch like
scream that appears to
come from your mouth area now followed
by an immediate sharp pain in the back of
your ankle and lower leg. That is likely
to affect your ability to walk properly.
Surgery is often performed
to repair the rupture.
For many people who ever nonsurgical
treatment works just as well.
This is not answering my fucking question.
Okay.
Why do they say rupture
for a killies? I can't believe
I know how to spell Achilles.
So big a fucking Zeplin fan.
I am. I spelled it wrong.
Achilles tendon eruption shows
you what to do if you take,
you know what?
I don't even give a fuck anymore.
Somebody has got to be a Goddamn doctor
or a first responder who could fucking
tell me what it means. Um, all right,
let me read a little a
advertising here for the week.
Ah,
ZipRecruiter, everybody. Ladies
and gentlemen, it's sold zip,
big Bro.
With ZipRecruiter.
You can post your job to over 100 of the
Web's leading job boards with just one
click.
So you can rest easy knowing your job
is being seen by the right candidates.
Then all zip
puts its smart matching technology
to work actively notifying qualified
candidates about your job within minutes
of posting so you can receive the best
possible mass matches.
No wonder 80% of employees who post on
ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate.
The site in just one day.
Even pimps advertise on this
and the easy to use zip.
Our owner dashboard lets you manage your
hiring process from start to finish all
in one place,
zip in the smartest way to hire.
Find out today why ZipRecruiter has been
used by growing businesses of all sizes
and industries to find out the most
qualified job candidates with immediate
results. And right now my
listeners can post on all zip.
Yeah.
Can I run over there for
free? That's right. Free.
Just go to ziprecruiter.com/birth that's
ziprecruiter.com/pat one more time for
free.
Go to zip
group.com/bar. All right. Oh
look who's here? Everybody uh,
[inaudible]. What's going on in
Kansas City to do to, to Mandy's brds.
Eddie Reed's got sweaty titties.
He showed that put that shit
on the side of his house.
He's going to get fired and
they'll hire a fucking Laos goes.
That's what Kansas City does. They torture
their fans. What the fuck happened?
He Superbowl dreams. Me.
He. Anyway, everybody.
Let me tell you about me on this.
It's the only underwear that makes for an
amazing gift. Soft, flexible waistband,
three times softer than cotton.
Naturally sustainable sourced fiber.
Mandy's made underwear. The perfect gift
that everyone is going to love for you.
It's a God damn holiday miracle.
You fucking bastard this year.
Don't give underwear. Give me undies. Uh,
this holiday season by do we do B?
It's the holiday season.
You want soft shit up against your nuts.
Not Literally Frequent Madel matter.
I can't fucking sing this holiday season.
Doobie Doobie.
Do to get your exclusive 20% off the
softest underwear and socks you'll ever
wear. Free shipping in 100%
satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash
bar. That's me on these.com/. Bar.
How many fucking more do we got
here? Dollar Shave Club. Everybody,
if you want to shave your balls are just
look like you have shaped balls. Jess,
uh, use dollar shave club
just like their razors.
Everything is super high quality and what
have you. Looking and feeling amazing.
Shave your nuts. Get some fucking me on
these and then fucking find somebody.
Lick your balls on Ziprecruiter.
You like how I'm tying it all together.
And then when you go to court,
mail something through stamps.com I'm
from premium ingredients to sophisticated
sense.
Dollar Shave Club is changing the game.
If you're sick of the
nonsense at the store,
now is the time to try out dollar
shave club for a limited time.
Dollar Shave Club is basically
giving away their shit. Shower,
shave starter set to new
members for only $5 to start.
A set features their executive razor and
three trial size of their most popular
products that help you
stay fresh and clean.
And your first box you will
receive their shave butter,
bodywash and one wipe Challies but wipes.
Speaking of Charlie,
I watch Ken Burns.
The end of that is fucking thing on the
Vietnam War. It's incredible. But anyways,
you will also receive
their executives sir,
which includes their premium, weighty
handle and focused set of cartridges.
And the first box replacement cartridges
are sent for only a few bucks a month.
This offer is exclusively
available@dollarshaveclub.com
slash bar that's dollar
shave club.com/bar and if you want a
great gift, give him dollar Shave Club.
I just said this shit that got,
they've got super simple gift
memberships and egift cards,
dollar shave club's high quality products.
We'll have you covered from
face cheeks to butt cheeks.
There is no better time to try
the club. You know, it's cool.
Isn't that Ken Burns to war and
they had a north Vietnamese soldier,
I swear to God,
his first name was boo and he wrote
a book about his experiences and I,
I got to read that fucking thing.
It's always great to hear what the other
side was thinking. You know what I mean?
It humanizes them when they're fucking
scared. They miss their family.
You know what I mean?
It's wow,
that never works in sports. You go to
somebody else's stadium is still like,
I don't like these fucking cuts.
All right, stamps.com everybody,
um, wow. They cut off all the copy
that just starts with, so do what I do.
Use stamps.com instead. Uh, I've done
this copy enough. I can memorize,
hey everybody,
this holiday season dooby dooby do,
don't go to the post office.
Stand behind all those old people that
took a shower with sitting in a fucking
lazy boy.
You know you're going to be there.
They're going to have all
kinds of fucking questions.
You're not gonna know what to
do, right? Fuck all of that shit.
Wouldn't it be great if you
just do it from your own house?
Whether that'd be wonderful.
That'd be great if you just
do everything from your house.
That's a different story.
All right? Do what I do.
Go to use stamps.com stamps.com brings
all the services that the US post office
right into your goddamn house. Buying
print official US postage for any letter,
any package, any class of mail
using your own computer and printer,
you bringing the post office into
your house, rednecks with guns. Relax.
It's not literally a
stranger in your house, okay?
It's just figuratively speaking,
figuratively speaking,
put your God damn gun down. Then the
mailman picks it up. Don't shoot him.
stamps.com makes it easy.
They'll send you a digital scale,
automatically calculates exact postage
stamps.com we'll even help you decide out
of the fucking boom, the best class of
mail every time. Print postage, any day,
any time.
stamps.com is always open.
I use stamps.com anytime I send out
my fucking posters and I want to get
sexually assaulted by drunk cougars
at the end of the fucking show.
And right now you too can
enjoy the stamps.com service
with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage
and a digital scale without long term
commitments.
Go to stamps.com
click a little bit of your boat
page and type in Burger, but you are
that stamps.com enter right mercifully.
That is fucking over.
Um,
all right, 38 fucking minutes in
here that I talk about everything.
I wanted to talk about it that
night. Then I, dude, I um,
oh,
you know what?
I ordered this old modern drummer
because it was right around the time John
Bonam died and they had this little
John Bonam retrospective.
I thought they were going to be a
little more shocked that he was gone.
They just kind of said,
you know,
he's one of the great drummers of all
time and he has all his beats and all that
shit. You know, it's really,
it's really cool. And like,
what's his face on the cover?
Let me see who's on the,
I don't even know who's on the
cupboards from so long ago. It's 1981.
Um, hang on a second. Hang on a
second as I walk across the room.
Okay.
It's uh,
oh shit. It's Peter Criss, Peter,
Chris and he's sitting,
I swear to God,
he is playing a pearl drum kit with
concert Tom's that you novices out there.
That means there's no bottom heads.
If you ever watch Phil Collins,
that's what he yet right and uh,
are still has,
he has a kick and a snare and then
he has one, two, three, four, five,
six,
seven rack toms in two floor toms.
So he has an 11 piece kit
to play one a rock and roll.
All Nat a potter.
Ever read David Doo,
Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo. Doo, Doo,
Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo
Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo
did about four hours later [inaudible]
data but it is crashing. Um,
that's what I like about these old
fuck these fat fucking kid is the shit.
And then they got like back
then they had all of these, uh,
they got these fucking drum kits.
Do you guys remember when they'd had the,
on the bass drum they'd have the,
they mount to toms and then they'd have
a third one there. When I opened this up,
Ludwig,
they've always had the inside front cover.
They actually sky from reo.
Speedwagon Allen Grad, sir,
he has four fucking times.
How the fuck did you even reach those
ones up top? Unbelievable. Anyways,
I love looking at this shit.
You look at like the bass drum pedals
that they had and this was like the 80s.
This was like 15 years after John
Bonam did good times, bad times.
So I can't imagine.
I know he was like the Ludwig speaking.
Look at Peter Criss kid
fucking British racing green.
He looks good, man. He looks good, but
without the makeup back in 1981 anyways,
I don't know. I'm going to
do that old shit. I'm sorry.
I don't know what the
fuck I brought that up.
I just want to bore you guys to
tear. All right. Tears sparky.
41 minutes and I can start reading.
God knows the way I fucking read.
Does anybody know how you fucking,
you remember your iCloud password
or your Instagram password?
I just fucking, I just, once I
lose him and then I just, I can't,
it's like I can't get into my own house.
All right.
Girlfriend's friend's
boyfriend demands and apology.
Girlfriend's friend's boyfriend.
All right,
so you have a girlfriend who has a friend
who was a boyfriend and they want an
apology from you. Dear Burbank,
bad boy brain, red bird,
red bird, whatever the fuck
that means. A Bill Burbank.
That's going to be my fucking alias.
A, I've got an interesting one for you.
A little bit of context.
I am 24 and two years out of school.
I live with my girlfriend
of almost five years,
roughly two years ago on a
sorority trip with my girlfriend,
her friend and her friend's boyfriend.
I gave the girl one of those awkward
side hugs after she went out for a beer
run. No sexual intent
whatsoever just to thank you.
Evidently the boyfriend felt otherwise
and flew into a rage shortly thereafter
and salting the girl and my girlfriend.
I didn't learn about this
until well after and since.
I have no relationship with the guy was
content to let it be and wait a minute.
Did the guys see the side hug?
All right.
Wait,
what the fuck happened?
I gave the girl of one of one of those
awkward side hugs after she went out for
a beer run. No sexual intent,
whatever, just to thank you.
Evidently the boyfriend felt otherwise
and flew into a rage shortly after.
I guess he waited to leave
and this guys a pussy.
Then what are you worried about? He was
fucking there, which she call him up.
Army fucking
touched this opposite side
shoulder of mine. All right.
Flash Florida for two years later.
The two of them have just gotten engaged.
My girlfriend will be a bridesmaid
and learn from the other girl.
I will not be invited to the wedding
unless I apologize to the boyfriend now go
fuck yourself.
Fuck this fucking pussy.
Why does he call you up?
You could be,
where do you that you pathologize me?
Why is this woman marrying this guy?
Two years later, he's still mad
about a side hug. Jesus Christ.
How possessive as this fucking maniac,
I feel bad for the woman
that's married this lunatic.
Alright for inappropriately touching
his girl. Well, dude, by the way,
I'm just hearing your side of the story.
You know?
Did you do one of those awkward side hugs
and then g Han came off a shoulder to
accidentally went across her ass if it
was just an awkward side Hug, I say,
fuck this guy out of respect for my
girlfriend, I'm attempted to apologize,
but since an apology is admission of
guilt and I didn't do anything wrong,
my pride is holding me back.
You know what?
Because you just said that actually
believe in you. I actually believe you.
I'm surprised that he's been too cowardly
to approach me and is having to work
through to people to get what
he wants. What we do do. Uh,
you know, and I would do,
I would, I would go fucking find out
what sports is playing in that area.
Tell my girlfriend to have a good time
at the fucking wedding. Love the podcast.
Loved to stand up. Thanks.
Um, this is what I would say.
I would just say I did nothing wrong,
so I'm not apologizing and tell that
groom to be congratulations on getting
married.
And at some point he might want to grow
a Dick if he wants to be the man of the
house or get some fucking balls.
Dude.
Fuck that guy five ago.
Go It fucking tractor pull before
I would go to the fucking wedding
of Jesus Christ.
You will be fucking hilarious.
Go to the wedding anyways.
And then after they fucking exchange
their Goddamn viles go up and give her a
side hug. Yeah, Dude.
Fuck that. Fuck that. I don't feel,
I don't see any your your letter that
there's any pressure from your now
girlfriend. Um, you know,
however, if you don't go, she,
you know, she might be able,
went to fact David out outlets and ads
and they're getting married. Your game.
We have flex my rain. You might have to
go down that road, but I gotta tell you,
yeah,
this might be a twofer.
You've very human dating this
woman for five fucking years.
You're not giving her a ring.
So what the fuck did I say?
You dump your current girlfriend and
tell that guy to go fuck himself at a,
you know,
I dump everybody in this fucking story.
Sorry, I'm a little
grumpy. Don't listen to me.
But I definitely wouldn't apologize for
that gun. I wouldn't go to the wedding.
I mean, Gee, you're a guy who the fuck
wants to go to a wedding. This is great.
You've got to know all right,
and just stay with that.
I just can't do it because they
feel it's an admission of guilt.
And during this sensitive time, this
climate, I'm worried that did this.
If I, if I say I'm sorry that Dennis
would somehow go into my Instagram,
which is tied to me Facebook and overdue,
make Twitter and I might not get a job.
Just call that fucking room.
Or You could just be a manager to say,
I'm not apologizing that guy.
Fuck him. All right. And then you,
you're fucking girlfriend. Unity
we, me, I would love to go,
but I'm not going under
those circumstances. And
I'll tell you right now,
if you didn't do shit in
the fucking bride wanted,
you apologize and you didn't want to,
I would back you.
So I'm not going. If you
want to go, you can go off.
You're not going get over here and blow
me and let's go to the game day. You Go.
That's what you say. All right.
Boyfriend rides. Motorcross dear bill,
I love all your work, your comedy.
Thank you. You're so inspired. Ah,
Jesus Christ here buddy. [inaudible]
okay. Where'd I'd like where?
I'd like your input.
Here we go.
I'm seriously dating someone who
loves to ride and race motocross.
That's fucking awesome. I bet. I bet this
isn't the same woman from the last one,
you know? I bet this is the guy that's
getting married. The motocross guy.
This guy's fucking cool.
Yeah,
this guy doesn't like a fucking side hug.
He's just going to fucking punch you in
the face with his motorcycle gloves to,
right. Uh, we've been
together for over a year,
so I'm starting to think about marriage
and a family with this person because
they're both 25. Well, that's, that makes
sense. Uh, he's awesome in every way.
And the person I know I want to be
with forever. Well, there you go.
But he loves to ride and race motocross.
It's not on the professional level.
It's a hobby.
A sweetheart.
You're going to do this to you
going to take away his fucking Abi.
We had a talk recently where I asked
him how long he wants to keep riding.
And he said forever.
I know someone who has two children who
husband had an accident riding a dirt
bike. He's paralyzed and doesn't
remember who his kids are.
Uh,
well, Jesus Christ is people who are
getting cars. I mean, come on, man.
What are you, what are you doing? This is,
come on, I'll tell you right now, if you,
if this guy who you want to marry,
if you want to make them fucking miserable
after explain this to my boyfriend,
he said his, something's going
to happen to me. It will,
whether I'm riding motocross or not,
I'm not going to change what I love doing
because of fear of what could happen.
Uh, I gotta tell you this. I am, I
understand why you love this guy.
I'm starting to develop feelings for
this guy. He's holding his ground.
He's riding motorcycles. I mean, you
take the fucking Marlboro man here.
Um,
I think,
I think that's a selfish response when
it involves your children eight to try
and, well, you get, you
don't have any kids yet.
All right.
You said, I hate to try to
convince them to stop something.
He loves doing so much,
but I can't imagine being with someone
who participates in an extreme sport as a
hobby when I have children with them.
Is it wrong of me to ask them to promise
to stop and we have kids or am I being
controlling?
Uh,
well first of all, the fact that
you asked that you're a cool person.
All right?
If you're actually questioning
your behavior, this is a thing.
I think you're a little further ahead
emotionally in this relationship than when
he's at where most women are.
All right?
Um,
and this is the thing, when you
become a dad, you do change.
All right? So that rather than
fucking Nag him about this shit,
just let the guy ride and
if you get married, okay,
I'm telling you right now, when you
get married and you have a fucking kid,
this guy is going to be so fucking
sleep deprived and so God damn tired,
he's not going to have time to ride.
Okay. Though, much as he used to,
which will then make it safer cause
he's not writing as much. But um,
I think there's a big thing you can't,
when you love somebody,
you have to let them do what they
love. Unless it's heroin. Okay?
Or being a pedophile, obvious fucking
things. All right. But other, you know,
if my wife liked all of a sudden wanted
to be one of those roller Derby Queens,
as much as it would fucking destroy me.
Watching her taking those bumps is their
elbow and them is there skating around
if she really loved doing it, you know, I,
I wouldn't tell her not to fucking do it.
I really would be worried
about concussions. It's
shit like that. I would be,
I'm not gonna lie to you, but um, you
got to let people do what they do.
Uh, it sounds like you've got a really
cool guy that you're dating by the way,
so congratulations.
Um,
and I think you're going to be a great
mom cause you're doing what a mom does.
A mom's already looking
way into the future,
trying to figure out where the danger
is and try to eliminate it. All right.
So thank you both. Lucky to have
each other just fucking relax.
Get yourself a god damn glass of wine.
Let the guy ride his bike. You know,
you guys get married someday.
I'm telling you when you get fucking
knocked up and all of a sudden he's got to
go to seven 11,
you know,
cause you want beef jerky
in a fucking fucking,
I don't know if it's some God damn ice
cream whenever you're craving is, uh,
you know, believe me, like I have
had to make adjustments in my life.
Um, I think you'll be fine, but uh,
you definitely really, you know,
you know,
they would say a good man's hard to
find a good woman is also hard to find.
And the fact that you're cool
enough to actually be considering,
am I being a Douche share? Uh, I think
you guys are going to be all right.
All right. There you go. Alright.
Neighbor, neighbor invasion.
Dear Billy Mango tits, I don't know what
that means. It's bizarre and I like it.
All right. I am an older lady, uh,
who just moved into a sweet cottage
in the boondocks last month.
All right.
I met my next door neighbor before I
moved in and I liked her instantly as she
seemed warm and funny as it turned out,
she's a Kramer in the first week she came
knocking on my door numerous times for
social calls.
Oh No.
And she will stay for
long periods of time.
Even if I tell her I'm busy
and she won't sit down.
So I feel like a captive
audience to her monologues.
I'm a solitary person
and I don't like people,
people coming over unannounced
unless it's an emergency.
This eight saint little house,
a little house on the prairie.
I have told her firmly on numerous
occasions to fucking stop it. Oh,
good for you. You're a
strong person. I like it.
And that would appreciate her emailing
me and waiting for a response or leaving
a note if she wants to hang.
I'm not sure how much more clear I can be,
uh, that I am uncomfortable
with the situation,
especially when I see her face in my
kitchen window at night, waving me down.
It scares the shit out of me.
Yeah, that made me uncomfortable.
She's even knocked on my bathroom
window when I didn't answer the door.
I don't wish to be mean. Oh No, you
gotta be mean. You have to be mean. Uh,
since I live next to her, I know
she's lonely and well, yeah,
cause she's a fucking lunatic.
What kind of can you,
that's look what she's doing to you
and you don't even live with their,
can you imagine living with this woman?
She'd be like that thing in alien that's
on for those fucking people's faces. Um,
I know she is lonely and it,
and I like to be friends with her,
but she,
but she just no comprendo
okay.
Love your podcast and advice and thanks
you ginger Moose knuckle for not being a
sex offender because all my heroes
are going down. Uh, well, you know,
it's still early in this game. You know,
someone could accuse me of something.
God knows. It doesn't matter. What
the fuck. I mean, I don't know.
Nobody really innocent. Nobody who's
seemed innocent has fucking, uh,
seem to have been called out
yet. You know, as a couple
of people have been like,
I've never met that one of my life
and then it fucking goes away.
So I think it's all right. Right. It
still makes you nervous as a guy going,
Jesus Christ,
you know,
this whole trial by social media is
kind of scary over there. All right,
let's stay with the uh,
the, the topic here. Um,
I, I don't, I don't know
when I would just be
like all like I can't tell you what to do.
All I can tell you is what I would do.
All right.
I would do what you already did
and um,
yeah.
All right. You want to know what I
would do when she knocks on the door?
I'd be like, get Outta here. Fuck off.
I would do that when she knocked on my
window and scared the shit out of me.
I'd be like, duty. You
want to your fucking mind.
You're scaring the shit out of me.
I want to be friends with you,
but you suffocate me. You asshole.
All right. Do you want to be friends
with me? Yes or no? Yes. Great.
That stop being a fucking jerk off.
Stop knocking on my fucking door and my
window. Stop crying. All right. All right.
Come on in. Come in. I'm sorry.
Let me make it some lemonade.
She's one of those people.
Um,
I dunno. I W W uh, I
don't, I don't know why.
I don't know what I would I get a BB gun?
Maybe shoot her in the fucking knee.
She comes over. Maybe she'll
think it's a beehive or some shit.
I don't know what I would do.
I Dunno what the fuck I would do if
you've actually told her that she sounds
like a crazy person. Why would you
want to be friends with a crazy person?
I think he just got it.
You just got to ignore.
Yeah.
Like the next time she knocks on her.
When you window like that,
I would just knock back on the same
on the other side of the window.
I'd knocked back and then give her
the finger. See how she handles that.
Yeah.
That's one way to do it.
The other way to do it is to start
talking about shit that freaks her out.
If she's really religious.
Just talk about how much you love Satan
and you've given yourself over to him.
Uh, I dunno what else you could do fart
in her presence. I Dunno. I have no idea.
I don't know what to do.
I feel bad for you. Um,
for some reason it reminded me of misery.
I just keep picturing that
woman walking up to the window,
the CACA duty,
whatever fucking come up to the window.
It's very American horror
story. Uh, wife cries at least.
So I hope that helps you out.
Um, I would just be more firm,
right? Or a letter. Dear
neighbor. Fuck off. Sincerely, uh,
solitary woman in college, uh,
cottage next to you, right? All right.
Wife cries at least three times a week.
Dear Bill Burr Baggins a big fan of you,
of your f you attitude towards life.
I don't have a fuck you
attitude towards life. Okay.
I think it's very precious and know that
I am taking notes by telling people to
go fuck yourself. All
right. Anyways, anyways,
I have an issue with my wife to
be because she cries all the time.
All right.
That's a deal breaker for me.
Yeah.
I'm sorry. I already had my
advice. Next time she cries,
just gently put your hands on on her
shoulders and be like, honey, honey,
honey,
grow up.
Um,
no, you can't do it. All right.
We've known each other since January,
2017 and our marriage was
arranged, not forced, but arranged.
All right. This is like tear and
rupture. What the fuck does that mean?
We both chose to marry each other after
our parents allowed us to talk on the
phone for a few months.
Oh,
what the fuck is this? What? What in what
in guy will cause she did. If they, if,
if they didn't allow you to talk on the
fucking phone the first time you poke
your head out of the
ground. Yeah. You're gonna,
you're gonna marry whatever you do
just to get away from those controlling
maniacs.
Anyways,
since we'd been together and she's cried
more times than I've cried in my life,
including the Times I've cried
during my childhood, everything,
she's crying because she
doesn't want to marry you.
That's what I'd be worried about.
She cries for various different reasons
and like her little sister annoys her,
feels like she's lucky to have me.
Feels like her parents don't value her
or she feels like she won't do me proud
as a wife. Oh my God. Oh my God.
Oh my God.
I don't even know what
to do with this person.
But you know that you seem like you're
from a different part of the world,
the different cultures. So, but you,
you do
seem to know it,
but oh my God,
Jesus fucking Christ.
I,
I think I would start crying. I just,
if you don't stop fucking crying,
I swear to God I'm gonna kill myself.
And that would make her cry even more
and just be like, what do I have to do?
Okay.
Anyways,
we are definitely getting married
is that line has been crossed.
So cutting it off isn't a possibility
to where the fuck are you in the world.
I love her more than you love
the freckles on your face, but,
but this is crying is wearing me down.
Yeah.
Well,
it seems like you still have a sense of
humor about it as I have to comfort her
every time and just stare at her
on facetime and she cries at times.
It just gets super annoying because
she does cry over small shit.
I gotta tell you something.
I don't know this woman and she's already,
she's annoying the shit out of me.
Anyway,
she has a busy schedule because
she's training to be a teacher.
Oh God. I hope she doesn't fucking
teach them under privileged kids.
She'll have a goddamn nervous breakdown.
Second,
she starts crying and shows weakness.
It's going to be over anyways,
getting a Postgrad,
organizing Islamic events,
parentheses,
no isis jokes please.
And she does and Islamic course at night.
So I understand that she
has shitloads on her plate.
She's under confident and she feels like
she's not the model woman you see on
Instagram. Although I assure her
that she is beautiful and I love,
or just the way she is,
I really don't know how to deal with
this or even approached the situation.
Sometimes I find that I am avoiding
her because I know Allie will lead to
crying. And what you have
you, what do you suggest
your podcast is?
Sex to my ears.
Nia is awesome and I hope Lola is not
giving me a too many sleepless nights.
Thank you for listening.
Old Bright Ball bag. Billy.
Um,
Jesus fucking Christ.
MMM.
I don't know what to tell you dude.
Okay.
I really, I really don't know
what the fuck to tell you.
Yeah.
Aye. Aye. I, I don't know how
to solve this. This is like,
how do you tell a woman to stop crying
in a way that doesn't make them cry more?
All right.
Okay.
You know what I do when my wife is going
to cry and I don't think it's that big
a deal at or I just don't
want to deal with it
when starts to cry.
Okay.
I just look at her and I jut out my
bottom lip and I make the saddest,
most pathetic. Just picture like
a sad clown. I make the saddest,
stupid face, stupidest face. And I looked
down while still looking up at her.
Just imagine that look,
and it always makes her laugh and she
gets fucking mad at me because she can't
continue crying because I
looked so fucking ridiculous.
And another way you could do it is bright.
Before you make that face,
you take a big inhale, you go, Oh man, you
just make that face. And I'm telling you,
if you,
if she has this sense of fucking humor,
that's what I would do. I the,
I think that's what I would do.
I would just joke my way out of it.
Yeah.
Anytime she was crying over nothing,
I would start crying with her.
Like, I just don't feel that I'm going
to be a good enough husband for you.
And be like, oh. And I would just be like
worried about that too.
Now you have to know this. I am a dick.
All right. But that's what I would do.
I would just start doing that.
And what's going to happen is hopefully
she'll toughen up a little bit. Um,
Jesus Christ.
Do you know,
fucking nervous that would make me if
a woman was crying because she loves me
that much and was worried that
she wouldn't be a good fucking I,
I would break up with her. I'd be like,
I can't handle that pressure. Yeah.
Jesus Christ born. What is going
to happen when she finds out?
I can't fucking read out loud.
Uh, mom's comment on pizza.
Good luck to you, sir. That's what I would
do. I would use humor. I would use humor.
Yeah.
You know, next time she goes, honey,
can I talk to you about something?
I would have like 40 fucking boxes of
Kleenex and just fucking run over with
like five boxes of Kleenex.
Just I would just do something
to make it silly and ridiculous
and then she might get upset that you
do that. I guess I would then say, uh,
the fuck would I say. I would
just be honest. Just say, listen,
I, I, I love you to death,
but why you delete the
amount that you cry?
I don't know how to deal with it. Oh
fuck that made you cry. Jesus Christ.
What do you guys see? What do, what do
you Islamic guys say when you curse,
what do you, what do you say instead
of Jesus Christ? What do you, what do,
what do you say? Uh, do
you say something you take,
do you take Mohamed's name in vain?
Do you do something like that and with
the whatever the fuck it is you say, I,
I would, I would be really
a, that would really fun.
I mean, that's a lot. These fucking
letters are a lot this week.
Okay. The fucking neighbor,
the Goddamn fucking Douche bag.
Who needs an apology for a fucking
side hug through two different women?
He needs to get his apology.
That guy, he's such a pussy.
What kind of fucking guy uninvited
another guy who a fucking wedding is.
If that's some sort of punishment,
he just made his day. You asshole.
If you really didn't like the side hug,
you should make them fucking go there. Um,
and that is the one cool check
who fucking boyfriend rights.
Motorcross all right.
Not saying the other people were cool,
but could lord life cries
at least three times a week.
I read that it's three times a day,
three times a week. That's still a lot.
It's 156 times a year.
That's what I would do. All right.
Three 65 minus one 56. Oh Jesus.
Two 56 to 50.
That's 100 9,494 days.
You're not crying
156 you are.
Okay.
That's like Marty Schottenheimer's
lifetime record that like that's the way
you're crying.
Days you cry versus days you don't,
and that's not enough to
make it in this league. Okay?
So I'm going to need you to toughen
it up at least two thirds more.
Why don't you tell us she,
she's allowed to cry once a week
unless something really bad happens.
Okay.
Um, you know, you could do,
you could go to the pet store and get
one little shocker college and every time
she starts to cry just fucking sapper. Um,
I dunno. I don't know what to tell you.
All right.
Mom's comment on pizza leads to break up.
I have no idea where this is going. All
right. Hey, bill weekly listener here.
Love F is for family and all your
standup stuff. Keep up the good work.
My question is what experiences
Ada.
Ah, good to see you
come on in. Come on. And
a knee at this guy's fucking
wife. Christ. Three times a week.
Why? That's hilarious. Did you
guys hear that? She goes, whoa.
Are you going to cry?
She cries because she loves him so much.
She just did a spit take.
I swear to God.
She does.
Yes she does. So what do you love
somebody that much? They cry at the,
that was the way. This is
the thing that they, they're,
they're Islamic and their
parents allowed them
[inaudible] like well listen,
knock it off. Exactly.
I was telling him what I do when you cry
baby at that time when you would cry.
And I just kept making that face.
I go,
which was not helpful by the way.
It helped me cause I just didn't want
to deal [inaudible] you, I know me.
If I'm crying, I'm having an emotion
about something and I Tell You something,
the jab is into like checkout and figure
out how to wait for you to deal with it.
Your job is to like check in and
figure out how I can deal with it.
Your job is to make me feel better,
not cope for yourself. God. Yeah,
but sometimes you just don't want
to deal with like, you know when I,
you know when I occasionally deal
just fucking deal being nice person,
be emotionally open,
don't be a fucking vast
wasteland of non emotion.
Man. Are you? Hi.
Yes you are the right not to answer that.
Um,
nobody cries. She's lying cause she's
not crying that much cause she loves him.
Can I tell you something? Do
you know like, do you know?
Occasionally I'll get
upset and I go on a rant.
Would it be great if you knew how to say
what your version of that is when you
cry? No, it is. No, it is no,
don't tell me how I feel.
Don't tell me how I react to things.
I don't cry. Like, don't respond
to my, don't tell me with your,
don't tell me I'm angry. I'm angry. If
I'm emotional, I'm fucking emotional. Hey,
can I finish this?
These people are Islamic.
This is an arranged marriage.
It's, it's not forced.
Just listen for fuck sakes. Can we
get over it in the mic? All right.
They actually were allowed to talk on
the fucking phone for a few months. Okay.
Okay. So yeah, these are,
these are fucking pissed
off. This is very respected,
secluded life here. I
got it. So, you know,
she's bur emotions are at the surface,
so she cries if for
little sister annoys her,
if she feels she feels
she's lucky to have me.
Feels like her parents don't value her
or she feels like she won't do me proud
as a wife. Oh. So whenever
she's having emotions basically,
right. What's a good way to be
like, honey, I love you to death,
but could you fucking knock it off
because you're driving me crazy?
How do you say that to a woman
without making her cry more?
Uh, I mean, yeah, she seems like
she would cry if you told him.
If you told her like, you know,
the t was not sweet enough,
so she's definitely a sensitive,
I told him to start crying too.
Like she's just like,
I'm just worried. And I was like, wait.
And I was thinking that
she would get mad though.
Probably because if she did it like that,
cause that, well then she stops crying.
Hey, hang in here for this
last one. [inaudible] happy.
No, I don't know. I honestly,
I have no idea what I can tell
you as a man, when a woman cries,
all we want you to do is to stop
crying. We don't give a fuck. Yes.
Completely fucking selfish when
it comes to our emotions. Yeah.
We know you're selfish when I yelled.
That's an emotion.
You want me to stop yelling?
Yelling.
Like hearing somebody yell
constantly is like traumatic. Okay.
When somebody crow all the
time was also traumatic.
It's like you want you to this sad
movie that never ends. It is. No,
that would be a real, she sounds
like a real drip. You know Jesus.
All right, come on. That looks good.
Well, what can he do? I don't know.
Oh boy. Oh boy, buddy.
It sounds like that's just kinda
how she is. I mean, listen,
I don't know if your religion
allows you to do this,
but I would get some
Bose wireless headphones,
the noise canceling ones who
whenever she starts crying,
I just put them on and put on
your favorite fucking music.
Can you ask her dad or her
mom or whatever? Like just,
I just feel like she's very
sensitive. She cries easily, you know?
Is that, yeah. I don't
know. I wouldn't do that,
but they finally let her
talk on the fucking phone
and then you're going to come
and be like, yeah, you know? Can you tweak
here a little bit this way of, anyway,
mom,
mom's comment on pizza leads to break up.
Hey bill weekly listener loveF is for
family and all you stand up stuff.
Keep up the good work.
All right. My question is,
what experiences have you had with
dating while going through our of, hey,
a rough term with your
professional career?
Bill has never dated anyone besides me.
I'm the only woman in his life that
matters and I really don't appreciate you
asking me about the people that came
before me. I got to tell you something.
I dated a lot of great women,
a lot of Hardee's.
There were absolute animals in the rack.
Uh,
my girlfriend and I dated for three years
and recently decided to go on a break.
Yeah. All right. You're breaking
up a, we met in law school,
both graduated with good grades
and each passed the bar exam.
The big difference between us is that
she got a job right after graduation with
the high salary and sane benefits
and located in a wealthy suburb.
This was largely due to a family
connection, which she openly admits. Yeah,
good for her. Use your
connection. Meanwhile,
I hope to get hired by a firm I worked
at during my final year of law school,
but was told at the last minute that
none of the interns would be hired you
fucking cunts.
Oh my God.
Fte sat there going through their card
catalog and whatever the fuck it is you
guys do.
As a result.
I've been living with my parents for
the past three months, making money,
teaching tennis lessons while sending
resumes and traveling for interviews all
over the state.
The decision for a break came when my
girlfriend was visiting me at my parents'
house.
She and I went out for pizza and came
back with some leftovers by girlfriend,
put the pizza in the fridge. But my
mom, who has a heavy Russian accent,
told her that putting the pizza
in the fridge destroys the flavor.
I did not even bat an eye
at the interaction and went
to the couch to watch a
hockey game. These guys live in the
life. He's living at home. He's teaching.
Tennessee's watching hockey is
eating pizza. I love this guy's life.
After an evening of my girlfriend moping
around, I asked her what was wrong.
According to her,
I failed to stand up for
her and was supposed to tell
my mom to not speak to her
that way.
While the defense or her girlfriend not
to put the pizza in the fridge. Yeah,
but [inaudible] in defensive or though
the Russian accent is a little harsh,
they can't help it.
Even when they're being like happy
and friendly towards each other,
they sound like they're screaming at each
other. They want to murder each other.
Yeah. That they're going to send you to
the fucking gulag. Don't get mad at me.
You know that shit is true.
And like think about your grandparents
and your aunts and your uncles,
like when you went in the room,
nobody gets mad at anything on
this podcast and yeah, I've,
I've curated some of the dumbest people
on this planet and we all just sit in
there and fucking bubble of stupidity,
enjoying all of this. All right.
After an evening of my girlfriend moping
around, I asked her what was wrong.
Okay.
Coordinator,
what I failed to stand up
from was supposed to tell
my mom to not speak to her
that way. I know my mom could sound
a little harsh with her accent. Yeah.
There you go.
And sometimes uses incorrect words
that you use your imagination
when speaking English.
But the two have always
had a good relationship.
So there was no reason to think
she would be upset by the comment.
This started an argument about how
I've become a mama's boy. Oh boy. Oh,
she went there and that I'm
not the situation and then
I'm not desperate enough
to move out of the house.
Woo.
Somebody's going to throw a chair soon.
Uh,
these comments really pissed me off
because she has personally seen the amount
of hard work and long hours I've
put into my schoolwork, internship,
passing the bar exam, and not to mention
she got a hookup and sending out resume.
Additionally,
this came a day after I was informed that
I was close a close second for a job I
was excited about potentially
receiving. Yes. So this is it. Yeah.
You seem branches. You know, land is
common. You like Christopher Columbus.
MMM. Nia was commenting on this all
natural ginger Ale. I actually like it.
Oh my God. Hey. But really quickly,
can I just ask you a quick question?
Do you consider a Ginger Ale soda?
I thought you guys would be,
do I consider Ginger Ale
offensive offensive names?
Do you consider Ginger Ale
soda? Yes. You do? Yes.
Yeah. People that follow me on Twitter,
I'll know what I'm talking about.
I did a poll on Twitter because I realized
that I don't consider a Ginger Ale
soda was because you only drink it when
you have, uh, when you're, your stomach's.
Not Everybody was saying to me, but
you know, I'm obsessed with Ginger Ale,
so I drink it all the time.
But people seem to, yeah.
Why don't you consider it
soda? Oh No, I have no idea.
I consider soda like coke and orange.
Do you consider an apple of fruit?
No. Why not? I don't know.
I know it's super obvious,
but I just never made the
connection that it would be soda.
If you said that on a first date, I, there
would be no second date. That'd be like,
this is the fucking Bimbo.
Jesus.
I thought I was dumb. Yeah, that's okay.
I can look it up. Let's try that story
in the pockets. That girl one time like,
hey, you want to go out? You want to go
grab some Sushi or something some night?
Oh my God,
I love Sushi.
But one time I ate it
every day for like a month.
And what do you call the white part of
your eye? I'm like, ah, the white party.
Your eye. She got here, it
turned all yellow and I was like,
hey bitch had jaundice.
Yes.
And I conveniently had another
call coming in that I had to take.
Um, well, but even if you thought it was
a bimbo, I still try to go out with them.
Like you are attracted to me.
I still try to go out with her though.
She was an underwear model. She modeled
me undies, me on DC though. She did.
Um, so anyway, uh, pizza, sorry
to interrupt. Okay, additionally,
okay, blah blah blah
blah. This came, okay.
So the guy was excited when I
suspect the real situations,
my girlfriend has an image of who her
partner is and saw potential in me meeting
that image someday. But right now
I'm not living up to that image.
It's like she's an NFL GM and I am the
potential franchise quarterback who still
needs to work on his arm strength before
becoming the starter in her eyes and
boozing it up like Johnny football
instead of hitting the gym. Um,
I gotta tell you something,
Dude,
I'd let this girl go and I have to say
something to do not fall in love with
potential and is a trap. No, no.
She, well she's, she's funnel.
Let's listen.
That's what I'm saying is for her to
like fall in love with his potential is
it's not a good idea. So it's really
about, that's the end of the question.
Yeah. He kind of knocked it off there.
I know. I gotta be honest with you.
I actually thought this guy was going
to do better with the question. Yeah.
I believed in his potential
for this question more. Yeah.
But I didn't go nowhere.
I think you grow couch,
Yo. Oh, I wouldn't say,
I think you'd grow from
making a point here. Um, yeah,
so clearly it's not about the pizza.
It's about like the bigger picture
for him and where he's at in her life.
And she's not,
she is like,
she's a spoiled Brat who just got a job
gifted to her so she doesn't understand
why she's still like good at it though.
Right?
Like it's not as if she just got
it and she sucks at it. I know,
but you know something he didn't,
he didn't say that he brought that up
cause I would have brought that up still
living labs. I'm sorry. I don't
fucking come from the Goddamn Walton's.
What are the, who's a big lawyer
family on TV with a Waltons lawyers.
Cliff Huxtable was, did you ever
watch the Waltons Clair Huxtable.
The Waltons was the Cosby show for
white people. What is the Walton,
it's just a bunch of fucking
rednecks living in an old farm house.
It was like 90 of them. They all have
fucking overalls. Sounds terrible.
What do you have against white people in
overalls? Fucking dilapidated buildings.
Can I John boy. Um,
that's that show. Yeah.
Denied whoever. Goodnight zones. Yeah.
Good, good. Good night. Mary sue.
All right. Bobby Jo, can I, John
Boy, John Boy who was John Boy.
John boy was like the fucking
oldest dude on, he was like a man.
He was like a young man,
but he was a boy.
John Boy is his dad John Too.
And he's John Man.
He's John Man.
We're not answering this guy's question.
I asked the question, there
is no question, but uh,
I think he just wants me to comment
on the situation. I have no idea,
but I would just say that,
um,
I would like, which, why would you
support me when I'm down? How about you?
How about your potential to be
a loving and supportive spouse?
Like why are you kicking me when I'm down?
Like,
don't you think that I'm trying to
make it happen? Don't you think?
I want to impress you. Don't you
think I want to be like, you know,
the man that like, you know, is, is
everything that you've ever dreamed of.
I'm having a hard time
right now. Like, you know,
why have that fucking four hour debate
when you could just break up with
somebody?
I see too many red flags here,
too many fucking red flags there.
First of all, they're both lawyers.
Okay. You can argue it out all
night long. Since they loved,
are they going to be competitive
there were in the same fucking field.
Then it's posted and then she gets fucking
pregnant and like who the fuck puts
their fucking practice on hold?
You know you would have to
obviously if she's carrying a baby,
like that's Kinda how it goes. Yeah. And
like she should be loving. So she's like,
so get your shit together because
eventually when we have a family,
I'm going to have to take
time. Fuck that bitch. She,
she seems like the Alpha male here in
this and I think that she's going to want
to keep working alpha
and then this guy can,
this guy can just fucking chill
out with the kids teaching tennis.
Yeah. I mean it's not like he doesn't
have a job. He's looking for a job.
He almost got one. Okay, well
keep at it. Keep your chin up.
I don't know both of these
people's on annoying. Why?
How is he annoying Boba?
Knowing he's like, I'm playing
tennis, I'm doing my best.
And she's like, get into gangs,
teaching tennis, whatever he's trying.
He's making money. He ever,
she had to play it to teach it.
Ooh.
You're like killing in
your own head right now.
I don't know what's going on with you.
You find yourself very amusing. Alright.
I do. Right. You know
something. All right.
I almost started crying like that guy's
fucking PR potential. Fucking wife,
his wife. Um, all right. That is the
podcast. I don't know if I helped anybody.
I don't even know when I talked about,
I want to thank everybody who came out
in Albuquerque and people who came out in
Tucson,
Arizona at fucking Dean del Rey.
Jesus Christ has been fucking murder and
in front of me. That's awesome. Yeah.
Like people is like an
audible like, Nah. When he's,
when he's fucking sets over to
knowing he's making me work out there,
crushing it, deans the best. Uh,
and I will be with Dean
next Sunday night oven.
Santa fucking Barbara said,
I want to go.
You go out and spend the money that you're
earning and go look at stuff you fuck
you and has nothing to do with.
What do you want to do in Santa Barbara?
I want to go and hang out and sees
in a and how much does that cost you?
It doesn't cost anything for me to
like see cause I'm paying for it.
Paying for what exactly?
The trip to Santa Barbara.
You are working in Santa Barbara and I'm
tagging along with you like what is the
problem? You just don't what? You
don't want me to cramp your style?
What do you and dean and I go, go dude's
like skipping to the vineyards together.
Then I'd go to a fucking brothel.
What do you think we're going to do again?
You're going to be there being
like, oop, you wear a condom.
I don't need that shit.
Listen,
if you can try to with that fucking second
grade manipulation to try to turn the
conversation into that goddamn direction.
I'm just going to steer into Nia.
Why wouldn't I be able to come to
Santa Barbara? It's a beautiful place.
I haven't been there in years.
Like what is the problem?
I'll tell you what the problem is
because fuck you. Fuck me. Why?
Because you only because you only
support me when I go to fun places.
You never there when I need you. When
I go to, when I go to Sacramento,
you never want to tag along.
I would potentially go to Sacramento.
I mean it is the capital of what?
California.
Okay.
Why would I go to a not fun city?
Like why would I do that?
Why would I need you to come along to
a fun city? I'm already having fun.
You love when I come on the row with you.
That's why I traveled so much
with you before us and he had,
these are things I say to keep the
relationship going on your podcast like I
that you don't enjoy me being there
with you and you're on the road.
The Woolies lowly, the road who I
lose you. Oh, here's the baby. Like
you're so in control controlling.
You're just like the man of the family.
Wait a minute.
Love when I'm there with you on the
road. So knock it off. Timeout. Timeout.
You're talking a lot of shit.
I didn't get lonely on the road
like this until I had a daughter.
Oh my God. Are you, are you see what
I did? A three week fucking run.
Are you suggesting that you
were not lonely on the road
before we had a daughter?
Are you saying for the most part,
yeah.
You didn't miss me when you're on
the road for the most part, yes. Oh,
so then who are you lying to you?
You so you feel better?
That's completely untrue. Yeah. Have
you ever seen what I do on the road?
I go to steams. I go to games.
I'm hanging out with my friends.
I'm riding on a bus.
It's fucking,
the whole game thing is you've got to
make your wife feel like you're not having
a good time out there. She's going
to get upset. Are you serious?
A lot of the times, yeah.
Oh my God, no, but now that,
now that I have a kid, it's
different you, so you never miss me.
When you were on the road all those nights
that you called me and said you were
lonely and was,
I was here and you'd saw something funny
and you're sending me a lot of those
times all day and text messages all
day like I miss you. Check this out.
Isn't this funny, blah, blah,
blah, blah, and like you,
that was a lot of those times.
A lot of the times it's bullshit you.
Almost 15 years. That's all been bullshit.
Not all, but a lot of it is
bullshit. I don't believe you.
That's how you do the road as a guy.
I don't believe you.
I will never trust you
again. If this is true, man,
you going to sit and
I'm going to Milwaukee.
I'm seeing the Henry Winkler's statue.
I'm going Fonzie,
I'm going to the fucking,
the Harley Davidson Museum.
They have a statue of
him. Why? What did he do?
Cause happy days was filmed in front of
a live audience to the audience there,
but it's not like it's rocky.
Do they really have a statue of him?
Yeah.
Seemed like a waste of a statue.
Okay.
It's like the funniest thing ever.
A waste of a statue.
The statue could have been something else.
Say What are you going to chop their
head off and put fucking Merv Griffin's
head on?
There
is that character that iconic
that it deserves its own statue.
A that guy.
That's why I love Milwaukee.
That's why I love Milwaukee's cause they,
it's a city but it's small town.
God Milwaukee,
you got to do better.
Oh.
Oh Nia. So me. That's one of
my favorite fucking cities.
Okay.
I love Milwaukee.
You know what Milwaukee Euro k with me.
Yeah.
All right. Near this is the, of course
I met you on the road. I love you.
I love our daughter.
But this,
there's times where I'm really
having a good fucking time out there.
So you have to text. Hey
honey, I'm thinking about you.
I'm not thinking about you.
I'm,
I'm watching SCC football.
I sometimes forget I'm married
when I'm at those games. I get it.
You don't have to keep like,
you know,
don't because you went so hard the
other way. Go the news too. Like,
I was so fucking pansy.
Any other panties,
man, you were like, you love me. You miss
me now I get it. So it was self serving.
Obviously you're having fun on
the road like you and you know,
text me pictures of you and Paul Versey
and Joe Barton like arm's length,
you know, skipping into an arena of
some sort. So I get it. I understand.
That's our tradition.
We always skipping
your breasts. Yeah. Fucking
rent a helicopter. I fly
myself to Vegas. It's fucking,
it's a good time. It's a
good God damn time. Alright,
this podcast is way too fucking long.
It's an hour and a half long. All right.
I okay. Can we apologize to
till the city of Milwaukee?
I will on behalf before we start
a social media controversy here.
All right.
I'm done with this shit.
That's it. Everybody. Happy Holidays,
man. Happy Kwanzaa. Happy Hanukkah.
Merry Christmas.
All that shit's coming up.
Go fuck yourselves and I'll
talk to you on Thursday.
Stupid.